[Musique]
non
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire dans la série d entretiens
politiques après jean-luc mélenchon
marion maréchal jean pierre chevènement
le général de villiers françois ruffin
david lisnard c'est le tour d'eric
zemmour merci d'avoir accepté mon
invitation merci à vous le principe des
cd de cette émission que je ne suis ni
votre accusateur ni votre défenseur je
ne vous combat pas je ne vous défend pas
non plus ce qui m'intéresse c'est de
comprendre pourquoi vous dites ce que
vous dites est pourquoi vous faites ce
que vous faites par exemple j'aimerais
qu'on commence par la couverture de
votre livre la france n'a pas dit son
dernier mot pourquoi avez vous choisi de
poser les bras croisés c'est un signe
d'ailleurs vous les avez là cet insigne
d'autoprotection a priori ans dit ce
type est mal à l'aise il refuse le
contact avec les autres c'est ça qu'on
se dit quoi ah oui oui oui j'ai je vous
avoue que j'ai pas calculé comme ça je
sais tu es une série de photos que
j'avais fait le plus récemment ouais je
voulais pas reprendre parce que moi vous
savez je suis je suis
quand j'ai quelque chose j'aime le
conserver et quand je suis amoureux de
l'une des rares photos que j'aime de moi
donc je me dis bon c'est là mais je peut
la tenir vingt ans le ridicule donc là
j'avais une série de photos récentes et
est donc on l'a prise mais vraiment gpat
attention aux bras croisés les bras
croisés géants plus est sacré toujours
le même illusion d'optique vos mains
sont plus grosses on a marqué ben vous
voyez vous regardez vos mains elles sont
plus grosses que votre tête là sur la
photo
vous m'apprenez quelque chose et voilà
j'ai pas fait exprès autre chose vous
avez appelé votre maison d'édition
rubempré et et comme bien écrit eric
zemmour ça ait choisi de mettre eric
zemmour en bas je sais pas pourquoi il
est mort en bas côtés de rubempré ça
fait une association or lucien de
rubempré limal héros de balzac c'est
quand même on le sait un journaliste qui
a fait toute sa carrière par les femmes
par les fausses nouvelles et qui finit
en prison par se suicider absolument et
la pression c'est eric zemmour dans le
rôle de novembre et alors je vais vous
dire pourquoi j'ai choisi rubin frère
parce que c'est vous savez moi j'ai été
avant tout forgée par les livres et
illusions perdues et le grand livre de
mon adolescence qui a déterminé toute ma
vie non pas le personnage vous comprenez
est-ce que vous avez raison devrait
faire attention
mais
vous savez le ce livre d'abord ça a été
un choc j'avais 13 14 ans je l' ai
d'abord vu à la télévision dans la
version de 1972 71-72 si je ne dis pas
de bêtises faudrait faudrait vérifier
mais y'avait yves rénier qui était très
beau à 20 ans j'en ai un souvenir ému et
d'ailleurs les globe trotters
exactement il était vraiment pas
franchement on y est ils étaient 1 rubin
près magnifique
d'ailleurs je tiens à dire que la
dernière version est superbe oui j'ai
pas l'habitude d'être voyez élogieux
d'aider des films contemporains mais là
franchement c'est très réussi j'ai adoré
ce film et j'ai et j'ai donc je
demandais à ma mère de m'acheter blick
j'étais vraiment un gamin jeu de bon je
trouve à 13 ans 14 et ce livre a été une
révélation d'abord littéraire et en plus
de l'univers c'est à dire de ce pari
2820a les journaux la politique les
femmes le le charme de paris le palais
royal voyez il ya tout et puis
l'ascension du jeune homme est la
sanction du jeune homme vient au contact
quand vous avez 14 ans c'est normal et
que vous êtes un jeune homme qui lisait
qui voyait qu'il rêvait paris de
l'histoire de france et c'est donc pour
moi ce livre si vous voulez je me suis
dit voilà je veux être balzac je veux
vivre là je suis tellement français
voyez je veux être tellement français je
vais vivre à paris je veux vivre dans le
milieu de la presse de la politique de
la littérature voilà il ya tout pour moi
c'est un univers assez à soi tout seul
et et plus tard j'ai compris tout les
tout ce qu'ils avaient dans ce livre etc
par exemple connaissez la phrase célèbre
de karl marx qui dit j'ai plus appris
dans la lecture de balzac que dans tous
les cas autant tous les économistes il a
raison incroyable description des
mécanismes capitaliste de la presse etc
c'est sublime voilà donc pour moi ce
livre est un tel tel choc de toute ma
vie et je les cochons relis
régulièrement que c'est pour ça que j'ai
choisi le ruban dans ce livre vous dites
que vous avez passé votre jeunesse à
lire balzac donc à lire hugo zola et à
écouter maxime le forestier léo ferré
mais les jours vous avez bifurquer à
quel moment vous êtes passés de léo
ferré et maxime le forestier et à la
droitisant pourriez ajouter barbara
brassens brel les rolling stones sont
renvoyés j'ai une jeunesse des années
soixante dix pas très original
vous savez vous on dit toujours on n'est
plus l'enfant de sa génération côte ses
parents il ya beaucoup de vrai là dedans
donc voilà et justement jeu en disant
cela je voulais répondre à certaines des
détracteurs qui font de moi un enfant de
maurras voyez j'ai découvert maurras je
devais avoir 45 ou 50 ans si vous voulez
ça m'amuse de voir
j'ai découvert barrès par exemple plus
jeunes mais aucun décès qu'aujourd'hui
ce que vous dites est plus proche de
maurras et de barrès que de maxime le
forestier de léo ferré rapide je l'aï
bien sûr évidemment plus près de barrès
d'ailleurs je trouve mais mais mais j'ai
lu aussi maurras il ya des choses par
exemple vous savez dans 2 qui l'attend
j'ai quelques heures de la fin du 19e
siècle il y a dix pages jeu j'en parlais
dans mon précédent livre le destin
français qui sont le résumé de toute la
politique étrangère du général de gaulle
dont vous voyez je ne suis pas le seul à
avoir lu maurras
voilà tout est fermé mais vous avez
raison je me suis éloigné de cette
gauche là
comment vous dire ça s'est fait en
plusieurs temps vous savez je vous ai
dit tout à l'heure et je suppose savez
que je suis sincère je suis vraiment
forgé par mes livres c'est à dire que
mes livres me transforme
pour moi lire un grand écrivain un grand
auteur je passe mes vacances à cela tout
merci ô vous avez tranché maurras et
barrès vous seriez totalement différent
l'absolu mans mais pas seulement mais
pas seulement si on m'avait caché par
exemple ten hippolyte taine origines de
la france contemporaine je n'aurais pas
ce regard cogez sûr maintenant la
révolution française j'ai changé à 50
ans si je n'avais pas lu renan je
n'aurais pas compris vraiment l'islam je
suis comme ça je suis refais a sonné en
permanence par les livres que je lis et
c'est pour ça que j'ai besoin de lire
tout vous comprenez on ne lit jamais
tous n'ont donc je veux dire je
m'exprime mal vous avez raison de lire
tous
les anti et les pro sur chaque période
de l'histoire voyez j'ai besoin de lire
sur la seconde guerre mondiale des
résistants et des collabos j'ai besoin
de lire sur l' empire madame de staël et
des maréchaux d'empiré voyez j'ai besoin
sur chaque période historique de lire le
seul et pourrait les comptes parce que
j'ai besoin de me faire une idée globale
c'est ma méthode est donc j'ai besoin de
ça donc vous me demandez alors ça c'est
la littérature et et les essais les
squares et il ya aussi le réel c'est à
dire que mon basculement sur ce par
rapport à ce que je dis puisque c'est ça
votre question d'origine
c'est
1989 l'histoire des filles voilées de
créer
si j'ai un peu de temps je vous explique
en deux mots moi vous savez d'où je
viens je suis quelqu'un qui dont les
parents les ancêtres sont des juifs en
algérie je vous dis bien en algérie ou
d'algérie epa algériens comme tous les
imbéciles le disent parce que l'algérie
n'a jamais existé a pour la france donc
on laisse toujours été une terre
colonisée coloniale romaine espagnol
arabe etc mais on sait traiter les
berbères juifs de nanterre que personne
n'a perdu la vie c'est la france qui lui
donne son nom d'algérie qui lui donne
ses frontières vous dites que vous en
faites étaient des berbères c'est à dire
vous voyez vous voyez pas vous ancêtres
comme des juifs qui aurait quitté la
palestine qui sera trouvé la question ce
que vous pensez que ce sont des berbères
je ne risque rien en tout cas ça c'est
sûr que ce sont des berbères est ce que
son est ce que ce sont des juifs qui
venait de palestine et qui se sont
agrégés au berbère ou est ce que ce sont
des berbères judaïsés on n'en sait rien
moi je je je je pense que ce sont des
berbères judaïsés n'oubliez pas que il y
eut un temps où les juifs convertis sait
il faut pas jamais oublié cette époque
là donc voilà ce que je pense en plus
chez moi il y a beaucoup de
blond aux yeux bleus à la peau très
blanche ma mère avait les yeux bleus et
la peau très blanche vous voyez les le
les vandales etc qui sont des clubs du
nord où les kabyles et berbères
exactement les kabyles donc vous voyez
pourquoi jauge optez plutôt pour ça bref
pourquoi je vous dis ça parce que j'ai
vu le processus et gégé et j'ai
approfondi puisque c'était ma famille
j'ai vu le processus d'assimilation
à travers ces juifs d'algérie autres qui
se sont d'abord agrégé au peuple pieds
noirs si j'ose dire honte il n'était pas
au départ les français d'algérie donc
les français d'algérie dont les français
d'algérie les pensées qui venait de
france les alsaciens les cominar il
n'était pas au début ils étaient
dérouillée il était plus proche d arabe
d'algérie qui les avaient colonisé et
des berbères chrétiens qui avaient été
colonisés aussi qui avait été islamisés
que des deux que des français d'algérie
en 2 français 2 de france je veux dire
ils se sont agrégés au peuple pennois
ils se sont agrégés à la france et donc
j'ai compris ce mécanisme d'assimilation
très subtile par les moeurs par la
littérature par l'histoire s'approprier
l'histoire mon père avait jusqu'à sa
mort un petit carnet dans lequel il
mettait les citations qu'il aimait de
victor hugo de châteaubriant et de temps
en temps il a utilisé il est ressorti il
m'en parlait voyez c'est ça être
assimilé à la france
mon père parlait parfaitement arabe mon
père adorait la musique arabe la musique
judéo arabo andalou comme vous voulez
vous voyez ce que je veux dire musique
orientale vous voyez ce c'est donc je
sais comment on peut passer d'une
culture sans la renier et s'assimiler à
la france et j'ai cru jusque en cette
année 1989 que les populations
maghrébines musulmane
suivrait le même processus
en 1989 pour moi c'est fille voilée sont
un choc parce que sont que 4 ou bien sûr
mais voyez j'ai pas eu tort soyez
honnêtes et elles ont retiré leur voile
après ça et pourquoi parce que le roi du
maroc a envoyé quelqu'un spécialement de
leur dire tu en veux tu enlèves ça elles
ont obéi au roi du manque pas la france
et deuxièmement je me suis dit vu que ma
famille et les gens de ma famille avait
fait le processus inverse c'est à dire
on est habillé à l'arabe comme on disait
en algérie et on s'habille à la
française voyez ce que je veux dire la
bise c'est un certain c'est un signe
politique vous savez bien n'est pas
habillée par hasard comme on est habillé
et je me suis dit là il ya un gros
problème il ya un gros problème parce ce
n'est pas une francisation j'emploie le
mot vous savez du général de gaulle lors
du référendum de 1961 ce n'est pas on
n'assiste pas une francisation on
assiste au contraire à une ré
islamisation
et là j'ai commencé à creuser cette
histoire là et à observer qu'est ce qui
se passait dans les banlieues etc avec
une acuité
je n'avais pas mes camarades
journalistes je n'avais pas mes amis que
là et ça a suscité d'ailleurs beaucoup
d'incompréhension de 2,2 de controverses
de rupture
j'ai perdu beaucoup d'amis à partir des
années 90 à cause de ce sujet là il ya
une autre question que je me pose et je
pense que vous avez commencé d'y
répondre je me suis demandé pourquoi est
ce que vous voulez défendre le maréchal
pétain c'est que y'a aucun aucun n'y a
rien à y gagner les pétainistes n'existe
plus au contraire ça vous fait perdre
des voix du côté des gaullistes que vous
voudriez séduire et des juifs dont vous
devez a priori mais sentir proche parce
que si vous défendez maréchal pétain
vous devez avoir une résonance parce que
si vous voulez il yad'abord d'abord il
ya le hasard c'est à dire que vous
souvenez dans le souci de français
j'établis tous les les éléments de
basculement français vous souvenez et et
j'ai étudié paxton en 1973 qui est un
basculement historique très bas dans
l'histoire de l'histoire si on veut très
important haxton c'est le tour de la
france de vichy et ses mamans
effectivement qui établit que vichy le
régime de vichy et responsables
complices hong kong à vis d'eux des
nazis et des allemands
ce que contestait toute
l'historiographie française depuis les
années 50 en vérité ce que je dis mais
que la reprise de la tête de tous les
historiens français de 1945 à 1973 on
l'a oublié aujourd'hui on ne veut plus
le voir c'est une querelle historique ça
c'est une première chose deuxièmement le
hasard c'est que pendant cette fameuse
émission chez laurent ruquier on n'est
pas couché où je présentais ce livre léa
salamé pointe ce sujet il ya à l'époque
sur je crois qu'il ya 400 ou 500 pages
dans le livre il ya quatre ou cinq pages
là dessus oui mais non mais je veux dire
que j'en ai pas fait c'est pas
contourner lui vous il ya le fait du
hasard après moi il nous connaissait je
défends mes positions mais la shem
lecteurs être livre là dans celui qui
vient de sortir vous par exemple vous
rappeler que l'armée d'afrique
a été façonné par le maréchal pétain et
par weygand par fichiers donc vous y
tenez la vérité historique et oui mais
vous avez envie de revenir là non non je
vous savez moi alors j'ai pas mangé par
émerger pas gardons je pense
deuxièmement que vichy je suis je et le
coeur de la culpabilité française c'est
à dire que depuis les années 70 la
gauche a inventé comme dans tous les
pays occidentaux d un joli c'est cet été
un livre sur l'espagne avec l'andalousie
musulmane etc c'est exactement le même
processus on choisit des périodes
historiques
pas très net
les pays se sont noyés se sont pas
toujours sont pas éclatant de lumière
etc et on tape dessus pour pouvoir
culpabiliser la population française
espagnole allemande évidemment anglaises
américaines et c'est un processus de
culpabilisation pour pouvoir interdire à
ces peuples de défendre leur identité et
leur culture et chez nous c'est vichy
c'est aussi d'ailleurs la colonisation
etc et donc si vous voulez je voulais
dire simplement
ce n'est pas vichy qui a entamé le le la
solution finale ce sont les allemands
qui étaient occupés la france était
occupée chez été la zone libre et la
france a fait ce qu'elle a pu c'est ça
que je veux dire je ne veux pas
spécialement réhabiliter le maréchal
pétain expression d'ailleurs de léa
salamé et d'une journaliste et
maintenant tout le monde la reprendre ça
n'a jamais été la mienne voyez je
voulais simplement dire un un moment de
basculement des élections 10 et 2 dire
que je pense que il faut arrêter la
repentance il faut arrêter la
culpabilisation parce que ça interdit à
la france et au peuple français de se
défendre contre l'événement majeur est
contre eux l'invasion majeurs
d'aujourd'hui qui est l'invasion volet
du sud et la subversion islamique mais
j'ai l'impression après vous avoir lu
que ça va au delà ça vous reprocher
aussi à jacques chirac et logique
d'après ce que vous voulez dire d'avoir
fait son fabuleux discours du vel d'hiv
parce qu'il reconnaissait que le régime
ne fléchit c'était la france que n'avait
jamais voulu reconnaître ni françois
mitterrand ni georges pompidou nil
charles de gaulle et j'ai l'impression
pourquoi ça vous pourquoi ça vous embête
pourquoi ça vous chagrine c'est parce
qu'au fond vous y voyez là la boîte de
pandore à partir de laquelle tout ce que
l'on appelle et la diversité aujourd'hui
va pouvoir revendiquer c'est à dire que
c'est à partir de ce moment là que les
enfants de la colonisation vont dire
mais nous aussi on est des victimes de
la france puis les homosexuels puis les
femmes de la même manière toulouse c'est
la diversité que vous n'aimez pas a
priori dont vous n'aimez pas le concept
j'entends va se trouver justifiée mais
c'est à partir de ce jeudi c'est une
entreprise de culpabilisation du peuple
français par son histoire et je vous
rappelle que ce discours du vel d'hiv a
été à l'époque on l'a oublié ce
qu'aujourd'hui on l'a sacralisée a été
dénoncée par tous les gaullistes marie
france garaud a écrit un papier le
dénonçant philippe séguin a écrit un
papier le dénonçons pierre messmer a
protesté charles pasqua a protesté je
vous rappelle que le général de gaulle
évidemment considéré que vichy n'avait
pas existé et que lui était
l'incarnation de la france ce discours
est le plus anti gaulliste qui soit faut
bien se rappeler de ça et c'est ça que
tous ces gens avaient écrit et dit mais
est ce que vous mettez pas à ce moment
là
volontairement en opposition avec la
communauté juive à la fois parce que
vous allez défendre pétain et que c'est
très mal vécu on peut le comprendre
parce que vous allez en vouloir à
jacques chirac pour le discours du vel
d'hiv mais aussi parce que vous allez
reprochés et vous le faites dans votre
livre vous dites que la guerre 2,2
des six jours puis la guerre du kippour
c'est le réveil identitaire
des juifs français et qui donc tout à
coup d'après ce que vous dites renonce à
l'aide des simulations cette
assimilation de vous dit le plus grand
bien en ce qui vous concerne et votre
famille vous leur en voulait pour la loi
mais la loi gayssot qui la première des
lois mémorielles qui va ouvrir là aussi
la porte à toutes les autres vous en
l'europe voulait quand jelen ce qu on a
toujours reproché aux juifs la double
allégeance à là aussi vous êtes du côté
de ceux qui reprochent la double
allégeance éventuellement d'aller se
faire enterrer en israël vous êtes
obligé de vous heurter à votre propre
communauté d'abord vous savez vous
connaissez un peu je ne crois pas aux
communautés je ne connais que la
communauté nationale donc c'est un
premier sujet de discorde moi je ne
connais que des citoyens français de
confession juive éventuellement coupat
est en jeu c'est comme ça que je me
considère c'est comme ça que je me vis
à l'époque dont vous parlez dans les
années 60 70
le premier à s'être élevé contre ce que
vous analysez fort bien s'appelle quand
même claude lévi strauss vous avez vu je
le cite c'est pas n'importe qui
donc moi je me situe dans les spas
modeste de claude lévi-strauss
d'ailleurs pour beaucoup d'autres sujets
je pense effectivement qu'à partir des
années 70 les non pas la communauté
juive les dirigeants de la communauté
les gens du crif le comme le grand
rabbin aujourd'hui rhein korcia tous ces
gens oui on choisit le communautarisme
meilleur exemple c'est le fameux dîner
du crif où les gouvernants et le
président république lui-même sont
sommés de s'expliquer sur la politique
disait juillet les vous mêmes
journalistes jamais même pas encore
journalistes jamais et ça m'a toujours
choqué d'ailleurs d'autres juifs
célèbrent et qui n'ont pas du tout mes
idées ont été choqués je me souviens
qu'à la main qui a protesté contre ce
genre de dîner moi oui je pense que là
les dirigeants encore une fois je ne
parle pas des juifs des français de
confession juive je parle des dirigeants
les dirigeants ont opté pour le
communautarisme et ont ouvert la voie à
d'autres communautés d'ailleurs vous
vous souvenez ce que je sais que vous me
lisez attentivement que les déjà dénoncé
dans le suicide français ça ne me
dérange pas d'être en opposition avec
les dirigeants d'une communauté qui sont
complètement en décalage en déphasage
avec une com avec avec les ch avec le
peuple c'est exactement le même critère
le même commentaire la même évolution
que dans le reste de la france le
décalage entre les dirigeants et
le peuple si vous voulez moi je pense
que là par exemple dans les attaques que
je subis de la part du grand rabbin de
france du président du crif si vous
voulez il y a au coeur ce décalage c'est
à dire que eux m'attaque parce qu'ils
ont très bien compris que je dénonçais
ce que vous avez analysé c'est à dire
cette évolution communautariste c'est
parce que je suis vivant je sais je sais
bien je sais bien alors que alors que
les les français de confession juive ne
voit qu'eux ils ont été à chasser de la
seine saint denis par
les annonces et islamiques que vous les
chiens qu'ils entendent ce que je dis ce
que vous laissez entendre eric zemmour
aussi par l'allusion à la guerre décidée
la guerre des six-jours et regan qui
pour aussi c'est qu'au fond
plus on est juif mais on est français
vous pensez ça que plus on est juif moi
on est français non je je je pense pas
du tout ça je pense d'ailleurs que mes
parents par exemple était très pratique
en pratique est strictement la religion
et il était d'un patriotisme français
sont cieux donc je ne crois pas ça en
revanche je vous dis je pense que les
dirigeants de cette communauté est pris
un virage communautariste depuis 40 ans
qui est mauvais moi je veux
revenir à la tradition assimilationniste
française c'est-à-dire
deux phrases simples de napoléon et
organisé vous savez comme vous savez
aujourd'hui judaïsme officiel 1 vous
devez au parle des juifs évidemment vous
devez vous agrégé au peuple français
exactement ce que je fais je considère
que je fais partie du peuple français
car je me suis agrégée
et deux vous devez considérer que
jérusalem sais pas c'est exactement ce
que je pense je pense que nous devons
revenir à ses fondamentaux et c'est sur
la base de ces fondamentaux que je viens
dire aux musulmans aux français de
confession musulmane n'imitez pas les
mauvais bergers qui sont les dirigeants
de la communauté juive imiter plus tôt
ce qui a été l'histoire du judaïsme
français de l'isra élitisme et assimilés
vous et je vous dis exactement musulmans
français jeu de la phrase la fameuse
phrase vous la connaissez de clermont
tonnerre rien aux juifs en tant que
nation tout en tant qu'individu et vous
pensez donc les musulmans sont comme les
juifs c'est pas parce qu'on n'est plus
musulman qu'on est moins français je
vous le dis ça dépend comment on
conseille le problème de l'islam alors
là si vous voulez qu'on qu'on en parle
c'est que
l'islam d'ailleurs comme le judaïsme d
origine l'accès est intéressant il c'est
la grande différence avec le
christianisme le christianisme introduit
une notion d'intériorité dans la
religion qui est une révolution à
l'époque
le judaïsme comme l'islam au départ sont
comme les religions antiques avant tout
des moyens de contrôle social et 2 et 1
et 2 et 2 comment dire on donne des
consignes sociale c'est un code
juridique au social voilà ce que c'est
que le judaïsme des origines voilà ce
que c'est que l'islam le problème c'est
que comme le judaïsme a vécu en minorité
pendant 2000 ans il a su s'adapter à la
révolution chrétienne
alors que l'islam jamais il a toujours
refusé vous auriez dû vous convertir au
christianisme comme au japon c'est la
religion vous préférez non c'est pas
l'argent que je préfère c'est la
religion qui a effectivement
révolutionner l'humanité et qui a
intérieur et qui a poussé alain à mettre
une notion intérieur donc effectivement
j'en suis le produit c'est à dire que je
suis le produit du judaïsme de mes pairs
et de cette conception chrétienne que
nous avons intériorisé c'est le cas de
le dire c'est à dire que ces cibles ça
on comprend pas quand je dis ça quand je
dis il faut que
christianisé la pratique de l'islam je
peux pas dire que je demande aux
musulmans de se convertir au
christianisme
je dis simplement que si vous voulez il
faut que l'islam devienne uniquement une
spiritualité en gros qu'il abandonne son
côté temporel et le problème c'est que
depuis milan 1300 ans depuis la
naissance de l'islam l'islam a toujours
obstinément refusé d'abandonner par
quelques quelques minorités à la marge
les soufis et c'est toujours que je
n'ignore pas mais tout le monde sait que
ce sont les grands vaincus de l'histoire
et qu'il ne domine pas dans l'islam donc
c'est ça le problème aujourd'hui de
l'islam le problème de l'islam c'est que
il ne veut pas reconnaître la séparation
entre le spirituel et le temporel et que
et que dans les quartiers où les
musulmans sont majoritaires
beaucoup d'entre eux impôts cela à tous
les autres musulmans et c'est pour ça
que je dis qu'il ya aujourd'hui des
enclaves étrangères qui sont régis par
un autre code qui est la charia parce
que si vous voulez c'est l'éternel si
vous voulez musulmans qui 5e' qui
s'affirme dans ces quartiers et c'est
inadmissible pour la france c'est tout
ce que je dis donc voulu nous et
musulmans évidemment qu'on peut être
français et musulman quand on est un
musulman qui a qui a retiré de l'islam
son côté temporel et qui n'a gardé que
le côté spirituel c'est tout vous dites
aux musulmans d'imiter les juifs qu
imiter les chrétiens exactement et de ne
pas imiter les dirigeants de la
communauté juive ont fait une pause eric
zemmour on se retrouve juste après
[Musique]
chine etats unis union européenne les
pays n'ont pas lésiné sur les milliards
pour tenter de remettre à flot des
économies malmenées par la pandémie de
kobe de 19 les plans de relance ccht de
la croissance avec de la bête toutes les
annonces de relance ont servi deux
raisons supplémentaires ou d'arguments
supplémentaires pour faire monter les
bourses pourquoi parce que notamment ont
continué des politiques de quantitative
easing c'est à dire d'injections
massives de liquidités et là on voit
bien il ya erreur de casting et comment
peut-on penser que le quantitative
easing est la réponse à tous nos maux si
on a enfin une vision etc ont mis sur
les les bonnes les bonnes choses eh bien
peut-être que on aura un plan de relance
intéressant mais sinon facile vous
voulez c'est encore une fois de l'argent
jeté par les fenêtres
[Musique]
pourquoi la guinée reste engluée dans
cette spirale de coups d'état depuis
l'indépendance jusqu'à présent on était
dans le même cycle politique un état
répressif des élites porté vers la
corruption vers le détournement de
deniers publics
une volonté de confisquer les attributs
de l'ensemble de la souveraineté c'est
l'adn de la classe politique qui a pris
la place du collège jusqu'à présent le
coup d'état du 5 septembre n'a pas
surpris est-ce que c'était prévisible
pour vous également tu était tout à fait
prévisible
puis deux années même avec monsieur
alpha condé deux pays étaient dans une
crise profonde à la fin de son second
mandat il a cherché nous pas tous les
moyens y compris des moyens tout à fait
inadmissible à se maintenir au pouvoir
[Musique]
et
nous sommes toujours avec eric zemmour
dans votre livre la france n'a pas dit
son dernier mot vous raconter que vous
êtes allé voir qu'est ce qu'on a fait au
bon dieu cette comédie
qui a eu énormément de succès les
christian clavier et vous dit le
problème c'est que chacun des gendres
reste enraciné dans sa culture d'origine
et vous le dit d'ailleurs pour tous les
gendres et il papa pour seulement pour
le gendre d'origine arabe mais en train
de temps on se dit forcément
c'est plus la même chose aujourd'hui
la france être français qu autrefois
j'imagine que autrefois devenir français
c'est l avenir d'une certaine manière
être français c'est l avenir aujourd'hui
ça semble pas pareil et je pense ne
serait ce que parce que vous le dites
aussi dans votre livre les lois de la
démographie s'impose toujours à
l'histoire or les chinois sont amélie
plus d'un milliard et demi les musulmans
sont un milliard les africains seront
bientôt 2 milliards en afrique forcément
on se dit ben l'avenir c'est plutôt non
alors pensez pas qu'il ya un problème de
nos sensibilités mais c'est évident
c'est que vous avez tout à fait raison
de nous rappeler à mes propres règles
démographique puisque vous avez raison
quand la france rayonnait et quand elle
dominé l'europe elle était aussi ce
qu'on appelait la chine de l'europe il y
avait en 1789 et en 1828 millions de
français c'est à dire autant que tout le
reste de l'europe les pour vous donner
une idée les britanniques à l'époque
sont 8 millions les russes sont 28
millions c'est à dire que aujourd'hui je
crois que les russes sont 150 millions
on devrait être 150 millions aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs si on avait continué la
croissance démographique français du
xviie et xviiie siècles avec les progrès
de la science et de la médecine on
serait 100 millions et il faut bien
rappeler qu'en 1900 quand l'afrique est
colonisée par les puissances européennes
il ya 100 millions d'américains c'est un
continent sous vide ray absolument c'est
très facile à cologny et à l'époque les
hommes et vous avez tout à fait raison
l'algérie quand les troupes de charles
10 arrivent en algérie en 1830 il ya
deux millions d'habitants les français
sont 28 millions comme je voulais dire
et la différence plus la technologie
plus et donc vous avez tout à fait
raison je prends jour 7 cette
comparaison jeudi en
1904 100 millions d'européens 100
millions d'africains l'europe colonise
l'afrique aujourd'hui 2 milliard
d'africains en 2050 500 millions
d'européens c'est l'afrique qui
colonisent le roi plus un peu plus que
500 millions cinq cent cinquante
millions c'est pour faire le rapport de
un à quatre quads mais on sera peut-être
à 3 milliard d'africains donc que c'est
pour vous donner un rapport de 1 4 qui
est qui s'est inversée donc vous avez
tout à fait raison
donc effectivement vous avez raison la
france n'est plus vous savez de gaulle
disait toujours on ne rentrera pas le
siècle de louis xiv moi je dis on ne
ratera pas le sec de la pole et mais
c'est la même chose on est d'accord et
donc il ya un manque de désirabilité etc
de la france n'est n'apparaît plus comme
la grande puissance fascinante où tout
le monde veut être français et on
al'impression plus et vous n'êtes pas
étranger à ce sentiment qu'elle est
devenue nostalgique de sa grandeur
passée mais ça aussi c'est pas
spécialement davis a fait ça ça
ça franchement
depuis le xviiie siècle c'est ainsi
puisque on perd la bataille pour la
conquête du monde
lors de ce raid et de paris en 1763
contre les anglais à partir de ce moment
là déjà les français sont nostalgiques
et plus encore après 1815 et plus encore
après 1870 la défaite contre la prusse
et plus encore évidemment mais ça on le
sait après la défaite de 40 et la
décolonisation donc voyez c'est un long
processus
c'est pour ça que de gaulle disait on ne
rentrera pas le siècle de louis xiv
tout ça est prêt maintenant il faut
savoir ce que l'on veut est-ce qu'on
accepte cette situation et on se dit
la france est un vaste terrain vague et
chacun y met sa culture et ses terrasses
on sait ses racines son origine et et en
fait ça devient très vite c'est en train
d'être devenu de deux de se passer le
liban en grand on voit ce que ça donne
ça donne le liban c'est ça notre avenir
c'est nous faisons rien tu as peut être
aussi suisse s'appelle entre-temps la
suisse la suisse ce sont les mêmes ils
plieront pas la même langue c'est tout
c'est important vous avez raison mais
ils ont cédé langues européennes c'est
l'allemand l'italien le français ce sont
des gens qui sont quasiment frère ils se
sont ils ont regagné une organisation
1000 en guerre quand vous avez tout à
fait raison ils se sont beaucoup tapé
dessus c'est très jusqu'au 10 mai comme
les français les anglais les allemands
voilà on est d'accord mais il n'empêche
que là c'est pas les mêmes civilisation
là on a eu notre civilisation qui
s'installent sur notre terre on a deux
civilisations qui s'affrontent comme
dont l'a fait nous sur leurs terres
autrefois
colonisées vous avez raison c'est ça ça
s'appelle la colonisation tout à fait
d'accord donc il faut savoir ce que l'on
veut est ce que les gens veulent être
ces gens là veulent être des
colonisateurs et est-ce qu'on accepte
d'être colonisés ou est-ce qu'au
contraire ils veulent devenir français
malgré ce qu'on a dit c'est à dire que
la france n'est plus la france de louis
xiv n'est plus la france de napoléon
c'est que c'est vrai mais est ce qu'ils
veulent quand même être français et là
il ya un avenir pour eux en france sinon
nous allons vers des affrontements
terrible c'est là où où il y à la course
de vitesse entre la démographie et la
politique la démographie nous emmène au
liban en grand la politique c'est ça que
j'essaye de proposer c'est de dire voilà
il faut prendre conscience de la réalité
et ne pas l'occulter comme sont tous les
politiques et après donner des solutions
pour essayer d'arrêter on peut arrêter
vous savez on parle toujours des années
30 et de la guerre 40 y avait pas
l'inéluctabilité de la guerre si les
français en janvier 36 lors de la remise
ita risation de la rhénanie par les
troupes allemandes avaient envoyé
l'armée française hitler était mort il à
l'époque il n'a pas l'armée et
d'ailleurs il a raconté ensuite beaucoup
de témoins que c'était la pire nuit de
sa vie comme les français ont cédé
renoncé à envoyer l'armée alors que
c'était jean oublier tout ça mais s'être
militarisation de la rhénanie qu'était
une région tampon entre la france et
l'allemagne étaient interdites parfaite
et versailles pour être clair donc les
français auraient dû et aurait pu
légitimement envoyer leur armée pour
faire rendre gorge à hitler ils ne l'ont
pas fait la guerre était déclarée donc
on peut si vous voulez vous comprenez
après c'est ont choisi est ce qu on se
soumet vous connaissez le fameux mot
churchill à munich même si à l'époque
c'est déjà trop tard vous avez eue nous
avez le choix entre la guerre et le
déshonneur vous avez eu le déshonneur
pour éviter la guerre vous aurez la
guerre et le déshonneur eh bien c'est la
même chose aujourd'hui nous avons le
choix est ce que on décide de voir les
choses en face et de dire voilà on
arrête tout on arrête les flux
migratoires on remet les règles de la
simulation on remet l'école comme elles
étaient on dit à l'islam qu'il ne peut
pas aller là et qu'il peut rester
uniquement une fois et une intériorité
ou est ce qu'on refuse de faire ça au
nom des grands principes au nom de la
peur aussi et dans ce cas là et va
inéluctablement on ira au liban grand à
la guerre civile à la misère et à tout
ce qu'on voit au liban vous dites
souvent ils vous le dit encore dans ce
livre que la france est le génie de la
guerre civile en face à des battues de
vertus les guerres civiles et là quand
on vous écoute je comprends bien ce que
vous dites et et vous ne dites pas qu'il
faut envoyer l'armée dans les banlieues
je vous ai bien compris vous l'avez dit
non je dis ça c'est vous êtes dans les
moyens je dis simplement il faut régler
cette question qui est en train de
gangréner la france il faut régler la
question des trafics de drogue il faut
régler la question des enclaves
étrangères aujourd'hui tous ces
banlieues ne sont plus en territoire
français ce sont des enclaves étrangères
donc il faut arriver il faut les mais
les refaire d'exemple affres des
territoires français et des français de
ces populations voilà c'est tout et donc
si vous voulez c'est un c'est un enjeu
colossal mais si on ne le fait pas il
est sûr qu'on ira dans le dans le dans
le dans le drame vo que je décris oui la
france a le génie quand je parle de
gêner vous comprenez ce que je veux dire
c'est pas pour l'inventer mais vous
savez la france est un pays on parle de
diversité
elle a toujours été diverses la france
c'est pour ça qu'il ya des affrontements
emmanuel todd que vous invitez souvent
je le sais à une thèse très intéressante
il dit la france est le seul pays
d'europe qui fait agrafé coexister deux
modèles familiaux il dit le modèle des
familles nucléaires en gros c'est à dire
les familles qu'on connaît aujourd'hui
et puis ce qu'il appelle les familles
souches plus autoritaire plus
inégalitaires mieux en bretagne par
exemple exactement et il explique très
bien c'est très intéressant d'ailleurs
j'ai toujours aimé c'est libre même si
lui fait semblant de ne pas le connaître
je le raconte d'ailleurs de m'amuser un
peu j'ai toujours apprécié cette analyse
qu'il reprend 2 le pl est d'ailleurs un
don 19e siècle mais
en fait qui explique les guerres civiles
et les affrontements français
particulièrement la révolution française
mais aussi les catholiques les
protestants voyez par la fonction de ces
deux modèles familiaux et là il le
reconnaît d'ailleurs lui même il n'en
tire pas les conclusions parce qu'il en
a peur on a ajouté un troisième modèle
familial qu'est le modèle islamique
endogamique inégalitaire autoritaire qui
enferme les femmes qui
pour certains
comment dire et violent avec les enfants
voyez un autre modèle familial qui ce
qu'ils proposent sur la le mariage entre
cousins pourquoi violent avec les
enfants très dur outre qassem atta on a
tous été violent avec nos enfants
jusqu'à la fin du 19e siècle vous avez
tout à fait raison mais en islam c'est
particulièrement vrai et sur tout et
surtout qui repose sur un système
endogamique c'est à dire on se marie
entre cousins exonhit com danger non non
non non non non je vous assure la france
c'est justement regarder les livres de
toute la france c'est justement les
changes entre la bretonne et le progrès
saint louis qui se marie non la france
est ce assez les changes ddd zone des
femmes etc non la lay line il ya une
nuit à un système mais je vous dis c'est
dans top c'est pas moi qui l'inventé et
on ajoute un troisième système familial
alors qu'on avait réglé le problème de
notre position de systèmes familiaux par
la victoire de la famille nucléaire qui
va provoquer qui provoque déjà des
ruptures d'aider des affrontements si
vous voulez si les français de souche et
les français d'origines européennes ont
fui les banlieues c'est bien connu ça
moi j'ai grandi en banlieue toute ma
famille agrandie anglais continuent
d'arriver d'algérie ils étaient tous
dans la banlieue est bon s'il y en a
plus aujourd'hui s'il ya quasiment plus
de juifs dans les écoles publiques s'il
y a si vous voulez ils ont tous fui tous
les français ont fui les banlieues
pourquoi parce qu'il y a là une autre
civilisation qui repose sur un autre
texte sacré connaissez le mode malraux
qu'est ce qu'une caisse qu'une
civilisation c'est tout ce qui s'agrège
à une religion et qui repose sur un
autre système familial et donc ça on va
dans un affrontement c'est pour ça que
par exemple la question du voile
est aussi emblématique je vous ai dit
que moi j'avais basculer en 1989 avec le
voile j'ai compris pourquoi avec le
recul parce que le voile incarne la
situation des femmes incarnent le
l'interdît sur les femmes puisque elle
est réservée aux cousins qui est
antinomique avec le système français du
que je vous ai décrit déjà leur salut
bien et pour que dans les familles
juives d'algérie par exemple il y avait
aussi les femmes étaient tenus dans une
ségrégation envers non non non non non
non non justement pardonnez moi non mais
je me traîne pardonnez moi oui vous vous
trompez je vais vous dire pourquoi je ne
dis pas que elle était libre de faire ce
qu'elle voulait que d'avoir la vie
sexuelle qu'elle voulait mais à l'époque
en france non plus ce que je dis c'est
que vous savez pourquoi de la croix
quand il va en algérie dans les années
1830 j'ai découvert ça récemment donc
jeu ça va vous intéresser pourquoi il ne
peint que des juifs parce que ce sont
les seuls qui ne sont pas volés
j'ai découvert ça récemment j'ai vue
d'aider des très belles d'ailleurs
reproduction et ce sont les seuls qui ne
sont pas volés déjà à l'époque et très
vite avec la france elles vont à l'école
française les filles vous n'entendez
frédéric les filles donc ce nom ce n'est
pas la même chose malgré tout même si je
ne dis pas qu'il n'ya pas des
ressemblances avons exagéré et
deuxièmement n'oubliez pas que le
judaïsme français par les femmes donc la
femme elle peut épouser n'importe qui
comprenait l'expression elle peut être
posée qui elles veulent le judaïsme
transmettent les hommes c'est par
l'islam c'est par le père ils
convertissent et surtout mais là où vous
avez raison c'est que les systèmes
endogamique était très fort dans
l'algérie de l'époque là vous avez mille
fois raison est que si les femmes juives
avaient été poussés n'importe qui il y
aurait plus de juifs n'ont que si elle
transmet à junas peur mais là non elles
transmettent le judaïsme est là où vous
avez raison non mais là où vous avez
raison dans celle l'interdiction elle
est plutôt sur les hommes d'aller
épouser même dans la dans la dans la
dans l'ancien testament déjà un on
reproche aux peuples aux voiliers aux
hommes d'aller bon mais là où vous avez
raison c'est hélas vous touchez un un
sujet très intéressant que même
soustelle vous savez le grand temps du
prologue un politique français et
gaullistes qui s'est opposé général de
groupe ce qu'il était contre la
dépendance même lui l'a reconnu il ya eu
130 ans de colonisation française en
algérie
contrairement à la colonisation mexique
par exemple par les espagnols et aussi
d'effroyables massacre 1 mais il ya eu
un mélange des populations en algérie il
n'ya aucun mélange très intéressant
quand même aucun mélange c'est à dire
qu' il n'y a quasiment pas de mariages
mixtes et quasiment pas d'enfant parce
qu'il ya une séparation des communautés
en vérité et je vous dis même jacques
soustelle qui était pour l'algérie
française c'est lui vous savez le mot
sellette du général de gaulle tellement
amusant qui dit l'intégration ça ne
marche pas il ya que les cervelle de
colibri qui croient que ça marche même
si elles ont elles sont beaucoup de
diplômés tous ces soucis elle qui est
visée la cervelle de colibri alors qu'il
est normalien qu'il est un des plus
grands esprits de son temps et même
soustelle reconnaîtra que il n'ya pas il
n'y a pas eu de maisons en 130 ans de
colonisation oui donc ça prouve la folie
de nos élites qui depuis 40 ans on fait
venir ces peuples là musulmans arabo
musulman africain etc ils ont fait venir
en france par millions ont accepté cette
invasion migratoire et et n'ont pas
compris que il allait à la catastrophe
même le roi du maroc vous avez vu sans
doute cette scène célèbres qui passe en
permanence sur les réseaux sociaux le
roi du maroc le père de l'actuel hassan
2 qui était un type d'une grande culture
française d'ailleurs j'ai appris
récemment qu'il connaissait les trois
mousquetaires parker qu'il était capable
de parler de des personnages pendant des
heures à face à un sinclair complètement
effarés évidemment lui a expliqué que
ces marocains comme il disait ne serai
jamais français c'est pas moi c'est le
roi hassan ii du maroc en dans les
années 80 parce qu ils n'avaient pas
intérêt ce qui devient français il
voulait pas tout son peuple non
contraignante highco savez les
dirigeants de ces pays là sont bien
contents que il y ait une immigration
aussi massive parce que d'abord ça y est
de soupape puisque leur économie est
défaillante pour la plupart et que donc
ils sont ils sont bien contents que
l'excès démographique aille ailleurs et
ils sont surtout bien content parce que
vous savez que dans la plupart de ces
pays là par l'algérie qui a le pétrole
mais
les envois d'argent par les immigrés en
france en particulier dans d'autres pays
aussi est le premier poste de l'awb leur
balance des paiements je vous arrête les
mots parce que vous partez comme je
crois que vous parlez de ça donne à peu
près toutes les émissions j'aurais
préféré qu'on ou par le jeu dont vous ne
parlez jamais mais dont nous parlions
très librement dans votre lit jose en
fait dans votre livre vous expliquez
très bien le succès de votre candidature
il ya 25 ans dit vous vous n'auriez
jamais eu autant de une
au pays des géants les l'ena ne se
prennent pas pour des rois écrivez vous
avec beaucoup de
lui et j'allais dire de misérabilisme
parce que vous décrivez littéralement
comme un an et au fond vous disent que
c'est parce que la politique est devenue
un monde de demain que pouvez
aujourd'hui prétendent entre 15 et 20%
des intentions nous voit de vote je veux
voir en fait il y avait pas grande
estime de vous même faudrait savoir dans
tous les papiers que jolie pour pas que
j'en lis trop parce que vous avez vu
tout ça on a écrit comme un mégalomane
et complètement fou de moi même un but
de moi même et c'est tard donc ça me
fait plaisir que vous avez déceler vous
un peu d'humilité j'en ai aussi dit non
ya deux choses honnêtement la première
jégo j'ai été enfant sur le général de
gaulle j'étais adolescent sous georges
pompidou et valéry giscard d'estaing ça
calme
on voit où le niveau mais d'accord
deuxièmement
je pense que depuis jacques chirac qui
était une espèce d'intermédiaires
d'ailleurs il le disait lui-même
entre les géants et les nains depuis
aucun président d'incarner la fonction
ils ne sont plus à la hauteur de la
fonction donc on peut prétendre
exactement et je dirais alors là si vous
me permettez une analyse plus d'offres
par ailleurs je pense que je mets sur la
table le seul sujet existentielle pour
la france et que les français en sont
reconnaissants et ils me le disent
partout où je vais c'est pour ça que je
souhaitais entre 15 et jusqu'à expliqué
geoffroy le jeune qui était sur ce
plateau ya pas trop longtemps il dit
vous faisiez votre campagne sur
l'immigration expérience sur
l'immigration sur l'islam sur l'identité
y aura d'autres sujets sains bien sûr
mais vous avez compris une si vous
permettez une analyse plus au fond
en gros
nous avons vécu depuis l'avènement la
révolution concerne la démocratie
plusieurs aires
politique la première au 19e siècle
qu'on a appelée l'ère des notables vous
souvenez guizot tiers des gens qui n'ont
pas de parti politique qui c'est le
suffrage censitaire
bon
vous voyez ce que ça veut dire on est au
parlement on est avec le roi contre le
roi pour le roi et ses et on est gros et
ont des gros et on est gros et les
pauvres sont maigres
aujourd'hui celle inverse deuxième
époque les partis de masse vous souvenez
parce que je sais que vous vous me lisez
j'avais écrit un roman historique qui
s'appelait le dandy rouges qui étaient
sur ferdinand lassalle m'a toujours
fasciné comme personnage c'est lui qui
c'est un ami de karl marx c'est lui qui
en allemagne invente invente le parti de
masse et la social démocratie allemande
que tout le monde à imiter on est en
1865 de 1860 à 1960 70 on a les partis
de masse on a connu nous quand on était
petit le parti socialiste parti comme
qui triait leur sélectionneur c'est les
meilleurs dirigeants l'exacte et qui les
rendait indiscutable exactement on est
d'accord
aujourd'hui on a une troisième ère
qui est réseau à chaque fois j'ai oublié
de vous dire à chaque fois il ya un
média le temps de tiers aiguisons 7
journal vous souvenez tiers fait la
révolution de 1830 avec un journal on a
vu dans par les divisions perdu
l'importance du journal
le parti de masse c'est la radio
général de gaulle
roosevelt
puis la télévision est aujourd'hui le
média c'est évidemment les réseaux
sociaux et ce n'est les partis
politiques sont morts pour bien
comprendre ça nos partis politiques sont
morts ou tous morts et donc aujourd'hui
nous avons l'air de ce que j'appellerais
pas les notables mais les notoire et
deuxième analyse si vous permettez et
c'est que depuis 45 nos débats
politiques sont sur l'économie c'est
l'économisme qui règne en maître
pourquoi parce qu'on est en paix parce
qu'on l'a fait l'apec nos deux
adversaires ennemi historique langue
l'anglais et l'allemand
donc oui il ya plus de 2 de guérir il ya
plus de tragique dans cette histoire et
donc nous dit pluton sur en gros combien
ont réparti combien on redonne aux plus
pauvres combien on prend aux plus riches
voyait des économistes est-ce que lequel
le meilleur moyen pour produire et c est
là on a eu l'air des technocrates
giscard chirac mitterrand a beaucoup de
mal à faire son trou parce qu'il est un
homme du passé il est un homme
littéraire voiliers et donc il doit vous
souvenez quel est le cours du
deutschemark vous souvenez comme dans
les débats à giscard lui fait la leçon
en lui disant mais monsieur mitterrand
souvenez quel est le noeud le cours du
deutsche mark à jean am aujourd'hui bon
et je pense et c'est là je pense que
nous sommes sortis de cette période là
et que nous revenons quelque part à la
conception qu'avait de la politique du
19e siècle c'est à dire parce que le
tragique reviens je vous ai dit si on
continue on va là traitement et que si
vous voulez donc on a besoin d'autres
types d'hommes politiques et on revient
au 19e siècle et design et qu'est ce que
c'est
ce sont les journalistes tiers
journaliste clemenceau un journal jaurès
à un journal
ce sont des littéraires culture
historique guizot et prend d'histoire
jaurès willener je voulais ce que je
veux dire oui je vois le trajet inverse
et consorts de l'ère des technos ce jeu
moscou pour finir je pense que macron
nez ou pas il n'est pas le premier d'une
nouvelle ère est en vérité le dernier
d'une ancienne aire ou alors il est le
premier d'une nouvelle ère laquelle vous
appartenez aussi parce que il est vous
avez compris il est là terminèrent parce
que d'une certaine manière vous
débarquez là dedans un peu comme
emmanuel macron a débarqué là dedans
sauf que lui était un produit de
l'administration où il avait fait l'ena
il avait été ministre ouais et vous pas
et que et que donc vous vous retrouvez à
la fois avec les avantages et les
inconvénients il ya plus deux parties on
arrive on se présente directement à la
présidentielle comme ya plus de grand
leader indiscutable on peut espérer être
au 2e tour avec 20% des voix
on peut même l'emporter avec 20% des
voix au premier tour chose qui était
impossible autrefois mais moi ce qui
m'étonne c'est que vous vous êtes là
vous serez candidat parce que vous
pouvez plus reculer ce serait ridicule
de reculer aujourd'hui est donc vous y
serez mais en même temps vous êtes tout
seul c'est à dire que vous n'avez pas
pris les leçons de macron justement qui
lui a été obligé de la partie en mettant
des petites annonces et en recrutant des
seconds couteaux des anciens partis vous
allez au à la présidentielle c'est dans
six mois mais pas de parti c'est
imaginable vous l'a gagné
vous retrouvez le lendemain il faut les
législatives où vous allez mettre qui
passer des petites annonces mais aussi
et puis après il faut aller face à
l'europe parce que vous avez pas mal de
comptes à régler avec l'europe vous avez
être intérêt à avoir des sacrés prauthoy
je vous sais tu pas peur de votre
amateurisme jeu qu'on voyait bien mais
vous vous trompez je vais vous dire
pourquoi d'abord parce que
ce que ce café macron il faut le
reconnaître ça est ce que je voyais
faire c'est exactement l'esprit de la
5ème république et de et de ce qu'a
voulu le général de gaulle le général de
gaulle a voulu souvenez la formule un
contact direct entre un homme et le
peuple pas les parties et détesté les
parties il conspué le régime des partis
vous vous souvenez mais ce sont les
parieurs mais dd solide mais pour
claudine etienne attendait ce sont les
partis qui ont dévoyé la volonté du
général de gaulle ce sont les partis qui
ont complètement
dénaturé la volonté du général de gaulle
là ce que font par exemple et l air avec
une sous primaire spes du congrès de
cesser le contraire de ce qu'a voulu
général de gaulle c'est important à dire
quand même donc moi je comme macron
d'ailleurs il faut lui il faut lui
reconnaître sa main si je suis candidat
ça sera dans l'esprit vraiment de la 5e
et de la volonté du général deuxièmement
vous dites je suis tout seul
et alors
d'abord je suis pas tout seul j'ai
beaucoup d'amis des gens qui se
s'activent pour moi vous avez vu oui
mais vous savez bien amers les lames
sont arctique s'est créée nommée on est
d'accord c'est pas voulu dire reporte
les
mais mais mais les législatives
macron à démontrer et auparavant
pardonnez moi un françois mitterrand
lui-même que le peuple français a
intériorisé la 5ème république donc
quand ils votent pour un président de la
république du nil aux notes les moyens
de gouverner mais mes 5 ans donc vous
mettez des dépôts vous mettez n'importe
qui comme candidat mais c'est mais c'est
je vais vous dire dans ma bouche ce
n'est pas méprisant vous comprenez c'est
la logique qu'a voulu encore une fois le
général de gaulle et de là nous sommes
pas un régime parlementaire ne sommes
pas l'allemagne mais vous avez bien vu
aussi ce que ça donne c'est à dire qu'au
fond quand on n'a pas un parti politique
derrière soi on n'a pas de relais dans
la population on a aimé on a du mal à
préparer des réformes parce que les
parades sont mal base au t1 bonne et moi
je ne suis pas tout à fait non vraiment
je ne suis pas d'accord c'est pas non
vraiment pas et puis en plus ensuite les
hommes politiques traditionnels s'ils
veulent se rallier au second tour au
premier tour chacun passe ou ça casse
est
sa casaque et sakassou
mais au second tour après on choisit si
je suis au second tour face à aimer les
blacks ont comme me donne les sondages
aujourd'hui la classe politique
traditionnelle devra bien choisir vous
avez vu qu'avec ciotti a déjà dit ben
moi je voterai zemmour libre aaa je sais
pas moi bertrand pécresse et barnier de
d'appeler à voter pour macron je pense
que c'est ce qu'ils feront mais après
chacun se détermine en fonction de ses
convictions de ses intérêts peut-être
mais après vous savez tout se réorganise
moi je pense que la 5ème république est
fait pour ça c'est vraiment le gêner la
saga mais vous votre programme est quand
même plus ambitieux que les autres vous
voulez vous attaquer à l'état de droit
vous voulez vous attaquer alors ob vous
voulez vous attaquer l'europe vous
entendez moi je t'ai de coûts ah oui
voulait refonder le roc pour nonu j'ai
pas cette ambition je veux simple je ne
veux pas m'attaquer à l'état de droit je
veux m'attaquer à une à la façon dont
les juges ont pris en otage l'état de
droit pour imposer leur vision
idéologique j'entends par là et ça veut
dire qu'il vous faut de bons jeux risque
autour de vous pour arriver à mezel à
vos fins mais je les aime vous nous avez
mais je vous assure vous savez vous
nîmes alors là je suis sérieux vous vous
n'imaginez pas la qualité l'extrême
qualité sincèrement des gens qui m'ont
rejoint depuis plusieurs mois les gens
des normaliens des polytechniciens des
énarques et vous mettez la société
civile parce qu'à côté on a vu là la
société civile qui est à qui est arrivé
et qui a renouvelé à 75% le parlement en
2017 oui mais parce que attention la
société civile des manuels macron n'est
pas ma société civile là je vous dit
pourquoi c'est une question de
sociologie emmanuel mâcon qu'est ce que
c'est c'est la sociologie des métropoles
des bobos c'est la sociologie des gens
qui pensent que la mondialisation c'est
bien et que l'immigration c'est
formidable c'est ça la sociologie global
jeu videmment jour je vais l'art parce
qu'il ya toujours des nuances et des
détails mais la sociologie des mails un
con c'est celle là ce n'est pas la
mienne moi j'ai une sociologie de gens
vous voyez les sondages c'est très
intéressant à analyser de gens qui sont
soit des classes populaires soient des
classes plus huppés qui ont comme point
commun d'aimer la france des patriotes
des mais c'est les traditions françaises
les moeurs françaises l'art de vivre à
la française d'histoire de français
travaillent et on a pas on n'a pas du
tout la même sociologie donc je pense
que ça ne produit pas les mêmes gens
mais ça prenait pas forcément de
meilleurs juristes jeu démêler
traduction française je suis d'accord
avec l'accord doré mais vous savez je
pense qu'il ya des très bon juriste chez
emmanuel macron excellent les gens du
conseil d'état qui sont d'excellents
juristes qui n'est pas mon idée qui
n'ont pas mes idées pas mon idéologie
mais qui sont d'excellents juristes et
il y a autour de moi je vous assure de
remarquables juriste mais si vous le
dites je vous espère merci en tout cas
eric zémour d'avoir passé presque une
heure ça passe vite dans cette émission
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]